When my toddlers asked me for candy this morning,
specifically the peach and apple ring gummies,
I decided to just make them some.
I started by blanching some peaches
and then shocking them in an ice bath after to get the skin off.
Then peeled all four of my peaches
and made sure to get the skin off
without taking any of the flesh with it.
After that I gave them a rough chop before adding them to my blender
alongside some orange. Once that was blended up,
I passed that through a fine mesh strainer,
added some honey and some gelatin.
Let that bloom while I got started on cutting up my apples.
I used a variation of Granny Smith and Honey Crisp.
Once those were all chopped up,
I put them through my juicer.
Always reminds me of the time I used to work at a smoothie shop.
I then strained my apple juice and added some lemon,
a smidge of spirulina, but be sparing with it.
Then I sprinkled on some gelatin for it to bloom.
I returned both pots to the stove
and heated them up until they became liquid
and then poured them into my silicone molds.
Placed these in the fridge for a few hours
and then got started on my citric acid and sugar mixture.
Once my gummies were ready,
I coated them in this
and these were gone before I could even plate them up.